richard gotainer bonsoir l'année
dernière tu as sorti un disque qui
s'appelait vive la gaule
est-ce que c'est au deuxième degré la
gaule ou est-ce que ça ne considère que
le pays la gaule doute bien que je viens
y avait
il ya nettement sinon anguille sous
roche enfin il ya un truc chalosse way
abus alors ouais la gauche alors le la
pochette était dessiné par par uderzo et
là tu récidive alors tu fais un album
qui s'appelle encore vive la gaule a en
fait en france il rend ça s'est passé en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que le
projet a été retardé parce qu'il n'était
pas à notre bout ouais et que ça a pris
un petit peu plus normalement le disque
de sortir et puis l'album avec l'oncle
livrée la casse elle devait sortir dans
les mêmes zones et on n'était pas
content
tout ça ce qui fait que tonton albert
j'aurais par la zone à
il m'a dit mais est ce que ce serait
provient de faire appel à marcel gotlib
pour faire l'illustration que l'afrique
et j'ai trouvé que l'idée était
excellente d'autant précédent que
d'autres libé pour moi est en fait je me
suis retrouvée autour d'une table à
trouver des idées de deux scénarios de
machin de bande dessinée avec gotlib et
j'étais emballé c'est le mot est faible
j'étais ravie parce que je sais c'est
drôle on a 1 m alors va te faire une
interview tu as du pot c'est pas la pire
on va faire l'interview à sendai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tellement une belle histoire d'amour
c'est demain oh comme c'est joli et la
plus ratée
c'était si hier voici la façon la plus
belle histoire d'amour
enfin la plus là il n'est pas la
question quelle est ta plus belle
histoire d'un message tu as répondu
c'est demain quelle est la plus nulle il
a pu rater la pure hague pour balm est
arrivé plusieurs fois c'est à dire c'est
c1 c'est un truc qu'on fait que tu crois
et et puis et puis qu'il s'arrête
brossard est déjà dans le taxi en
rentrant à la maison c'est la panne en
arrivant ouais même là non parce que là
bas la panne ça pourrait être rigolo je
ne sais pas ça qui peut empêcher quoi
laisser c'est la déception sur un truc
d'état d'esprit tu te rends compte que
tu es mon fait finalement tu peux pas
faire tu peux pas faire route avec un
mental à trouver une partenaire mais
t'as pas trouvé une complice qu'est ce
que tu préfères dans le sexe
[Musique]
alors là c'est difficile parce qu'il ya
quand même plein de choses est ce que tu
peux faire de tout jeunes ont
honnêtement alors non je peux pas je
peux pas parce qu'il ya plein de bruit
que tu préfères tu peux le dire d'entrée
mais quelques dents qu'est ce que tu
entends par là là quelle est la chose du
sexe que tu préfères calé dans tout ce
qu'on fait avec les pépés mettons le
truc que tu préfères je veux rester
classique quoi bonne pénétration
finalement je veux dire vous tout le
reste ça reste je viens tu préfères les
amuse gueule et tout cela mais
finalement ce que tu ce qui dégoûte dans
le sexe parce que vraiment c'est gerber
ragdi penser déjà à tema non mais alors
là ce qui pourrait me faire
gerber ou mal c'est des trucs c'est des
déviations ouais la déviation qui me
dégoûte le plus c'est des trucs qui sont
tellement loin de moi que ce n'est pas
parti du sexe et zoophilie d'abord
scatophilie
photo la zoophilie la scatophilie par
exemple ce qui coûte le plus c'est quoi
ce que tu préfères en toi ce que je
préfère en moi ouais c'est quand je suis
drôle
ouais j'aime bien ça oui quand je le
suis je pas toujours drôle mais quand je
le suis j'aime bien c'est parce que tu
détestes en toi quand je suis pas drôle
l'émission de télé qui préfère ça
ressemblerait à des documentaires sur
les crevettes ou des papillons j'aime
bien ça j'aime bien en fait j'aime assez
les émissions dites comment dirais-je
éducative
ouais alors ça va prendre des trucs quoi
ouais c'est ça ça peut être ce que je
suis tombé sur un dock ozanam plaire ou
à
ou un truc dans la peinture ou grâce à
ses lacets maintenant alors pour finir
puisque tu sors un disque en fait à
ranger ta promo de l'émission de télé
que tu trouves la pure zinc de toute la
télé française
allez je crois je crois que c'est les
émissions de jeux inutiles qui sont qui
font même pas appel à des compétences ou
lé talent ou de garde bien de citer à
20h pendant 20 à 20h30 j'en ai gens non
c'est pas c'est pas les plus nuls
ouais c'est les jeux émission génère 2
faut deviner c'est le juste prix par
exemple je trouve ça vaut combien tomber
honnêtement j'en sais rien honnêtement
j'en sais rien c'est pas ça doit valoir
17 au 20 matches par an c'est rien vous
avez juste bravo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus